[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARTUR TSURKAN: So the
theme for this talk really
is thinking about,
how can Android
empower you, the developer, to
enable your app to help users
get things done?
And on the team, we
really think a lot
about how to give
your app superpowers
so you can help users
throughout the operating system,
even when users aren't
necessarily in the full screen
experience of your app.
For this talk, we'll
focus on three major areas
that you can take
advantage of in Android
Q. The first is with sharing.
Next, we'll talk a little
bit about notifications.
And finally, we'll discuss new
details around multitasking.
So in Android Q, we're excited
to have launched our redesigned
Share Sheet experience.
And there's a number
of improvements
that we've made for
improving users' experience.
So the first is around
much improved performance
through a new API
that we've introduced,
that we're going to talk
about in a little more detail.
We've also actually
updated the user experience
to make it simpler for users
to figure out where they
can share their content to you.
So the Share Sheet
is now going to be
organized into three sections.
The first is going to clarify,
what is the content that users
can share to?
And we'll provide a
default experience
of what that looks like,
but you, as a developer,
can also provide
additional metadata
to provide a richer preview.
Next up, are our direct
sharing shortcuts
where you can share within apps.
And then, finally,
are the app targets,
which have been split
into two sections--
some which are suggested
by the operating system,
and then finally the
full alphabetical list.
And you'll see that it's
a very familiar interface
to our launcher.
We've also included a lot of new
developer customization options
because we understand
that a lot of developers
need to tailor their Share
Sheet for various use cases,
and we want to enable and
empower developers to do so.
So one area that I want
to highlight in particular
is the Sharing Shortcuts API.
And really, the goal of
the Sharing Shortcuts API
is to allow users to share
more directly within your apps.
These sit above the app targets
that users can share to,
and they can include
targets like a close friend
that you are in contact
frequently with,
or an important work folder.
Because of the
performance benefit
that they provide
users, we're going
to actually rank these ahead
of the old chooser targets.
And so we encourage
your adoption
so users can take advantage
of these in their API.
Switching gears now
into notifications.
One thing that we looked at
the start of this release
is we found that 75% of
our users get at least one
buzzing notification or
noise-making notification
every hour, and 15% of users get
these every 10 waking minutes.
So we thought, how can we help
users manage this overload?
And so we're introducing the
concept of Gentle Notifications
in Q. And really, the goal
of Gentle Notifications
is to help organize those
important and valuable
notifications that
users want to consume
but that aren't time
sensitive and that they
can consume on whatever
their own schedule is.
And so the story
is, for developers,
that you still set the
priority as you normally would.
Users can still
adjust that priority,
but now the system will also
help adjust that priority
on behalf of users.
And this will mainly
target notifications
that are set with
the default priority.
In AOSP and in Q, the system
will use a heuristic model,
but we also will
be incorporating
on-device machine learning to
make this a better experience.
Having organized
notifications, the next step
is to make them even richer
and more useful to users.
And so the way that we're
tackling this problem
is by enhancing
these notifications
with suggested actions.
There are two use cases that
we're targeting for this.
The first is by suggesting
responses for users
to reply to with messages,
as well as providing access
to actions that are
related to the content
of the notification.
So now, messaging
notifications on Android
will contain actions to
navigate to an address
that maybe your friend mentioned
for a restaurant to meet up at,
or to open a URL that your
friend wants to check out.
Finally, we're really
excited to be announcing
the Bubbles API, which is a new
multitasking feature for users.
This allows users to keep track
of their most important tasks
and be able to access
them at any time
anywhere in the
operating system.
How this will work is users
will have a floating icon.
They can drag it anywhere
that is useful to them,
and then they can tap to expand
it to get the full custom
app UI.
We're prioritizing
communication tasks
as those that can bubble
from a notification
because these are often the
most important tasks to a user
on their phone,
while also users will
be able to pin the task
from within your full screen
app for other use cases.
And I think it's
really useful to review
how this sits alongside our
other multitasking features,
namely picture-in-picture.
The big difference
between these features
is that, really, what
picture-in-picture
is meant to do is provide users
with a path to visually monitor
an important task.
And it's meant to be a low
interaction feature, something
that you keep alongside you so
that you can watch while you're
performing some primary task.
So you can watch a video
going on or some directions
that you're following.
With Bubbles, the
goal is to help
users get to another task
as quickly as possible.
And they are often
high-interactive UIs.
So that's where a
friend has messaged you
and you want to get
back to them quickly,
and you really want to do
so with the full fidelity
of the messaging app
that you're using.
So you'll expand
the Bubble inline
without losing your
current context, and then
message to your
friend and go back
to what you were
previously doing.
We hope that this suite
of multitasking features
unlocks a number
of new capabilities
that your apps can take
advantage of and create
great new user experiences.
So now, I'm going to
hand it over to Mike
to talk a little bit more about
how you can take advantage
of sharing features.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE DIGMAN: So we've made
some big changes to the way
that Share Sheet works
in Android Q. Let's hit
the details that
matter most to you.
We know folks like
sharing straight
to the person they want
to over the app they
want with a single tap.
Who doesn't?
We're shooting to make this
experience even better.
So now, we'll show up to
eight deep linked targets,
but we know that
loading ChooserTargets
from every installed
ChooserTargetService
on a user's phone
can be a little slow.
So to make loading deep
link targets faster,
we need a new architecture.
So in Q, we're extending the
Shortcuts API to do just that.
Publish a dynamic
shortcut, and Android
will load and rank much
faster than we could
with direct share.
Previously, we would only
consider two ChooserTargets
per ChooserTargetService,
and now we'll
consider all of the
Sharing Shortcuts
that you provide instead
of just those two.
As an added bonus, because
you're publishing shortcuts,
those published targets may
also appear if you long-press
your app in Launcher.
To give users the best sharing
experience we can offer,
Sharing Shortcuts will
supersede ChooserTargetService.
We've made it so that
Sharing Shortcuts will
be ranked above all
targets provided
by any ChooserTargetService
on a user's phone.
So if you want your targets
to be seen on Q plus devices,
please update your app.
And we've made that relatively
easy through AndroidX.
Implement Sharing
Shortcuts with AndroidX,
and you can get a backcompat
ChooserTargetService
for older devices with a
tiny amount of extra effort.
The new API to do this is
pretty straightforward.
Make and publish a
dynamic shortcut,
like you would normally,
with the addition
of the required Category field
and the highly encouraged
Person field.
Adding a well-formatted
Person object
to this and relevant
notifications,
your app pushes can help
improve your ranking.
So for your own
sake, please do so.
Sharing Shortcuts
must be associated
with an activity that has a
category matching your shortcut
category.
And that activity must have
an ACTION_SEND intent filter,
which you'd have already if this
activity appears in the Share
Sheet.
If you want AndroidX to
automatically generate
a backcompat
ChooserTargetService for you,
you'll need to include extra
metadata under that activity
in the manifest.
Documentation on how to
do this is available now.
Sometimes, when you
hit the Share button,
it's not exactly clear
what you're sharing.
We know this is a problem.
And so to help with
that, we've added
a system-generated preview for
several different mime types.
It's now way easier
to copy text.
In some cases, though,
even seeing the exact text
of the thing you're about to
share is hard to understand.
Think a long, complicated
URL or a really messy URI.
In these cases, a rich
preview can provide your users
real reassurance of what
they're about to send.
So for text previews
specifically,
you can add a thumbnail
and description
to provide your
users that context.
Pull this off with clip
data and extra title.
Let me show you how.
Make a sharing intent,
as you would normally.
Then add rich preview
metadata to your share intent
before calling createChooser.
Stuff the description
and extra title,
and add the thumbnail
to clip data.
As a gotcha, make sure to
give us the right permissions
to read your thumbnail image,
otherwise it won't appear.
See the addFlags
method in this example.
We've heard from
developers that you really
want a way to provide
hooks back to your app
from within the Share Sheet.
You can now provide a limited
number of ChooserTarget objects
that will be shown ahead
of sharing shortcuts
and any ChooserTargets loaded
from ChooserTargetServices
on the phone, as
shown in this image.
You can also provide a limited
number of intents that point
to activities that will be shown
ahead of any app suggestions.
You can pull this
off as you might
expect with extra ChooserTargets
and extra initial intents.
It's really important
to call out here
that users like and use
deep link targets and app
suggestions.
For every intent
and ChooserTarget
you include, it reduces
the number of suggestions
available to your users.
So please use this
feature with care.
Through user studies,
we've learned
that folks almost always think
of the person and the app
they want to share to before
they ever hit the Share button.
To make it easier for users
to find that app that they're
looking for, we've alphabetized
app share targets by app name.
And important for you,
we've changed the way
that targets look.
We will show your
application icon,
as defined in the manifest, and
ignore any provided activity
or intent filter icon.
For app targets, we will
show the application label
very prominently.
It's what we alphabetize by.
And any activity
or intent filter
label less so, as you
can see in the example.
This is all to help users
quickly find your app.
So please update
your application icon
and label so users understand
what they're sharing to.
Often, the application
label alone
is enough context for users.
Finally, we wrap and shape
app icons, just like Launcher.
So please use adaptive
icons, if you aren't already,
to make your app
icon look great.
There's a ton of other
things Share Sheet can
do for you on Android
Q. And you can
find more info and developer
documentation coming soon.
Now over to Toki for
notification actions.
[APPLAUSE]
ABODUNRINWA TOKI: OK.
So in Android Q,
the system can now
generate suggested actions
for your notification.
This happens for
messaging notifications.
The types of suggestions
that the system now generates
include text replies or
deep links into apps.
So if you have a message in
notification, for example,
we would automatically just
generate suggestions for this.
We think this will help
improve how users engage
with your app's notifications.
So for example, if a friend of
mine texts me through your app
and says, hey, let's
meet at this address,
then the system can generate
suggestions, such as yeah,
sure, or no, I can't make
it, or give me a deep link
to Maps to see the address
or navigate to that address.
The way this works
is the system takes
the content of the
notification, runs it
through machine learning
models, and tries
to understand the content
of that notification
and what the user might
like to do with this.
And then it will pop
those actions inside
of your notification.
Let's have a look
at how you could--
oh, sorry.
There's one other feature
that you can enable with this.
It's called Tap to Edit.
Whenever the system generates
a text reply and a user
clicks the reply,
what you could do
is you can enable the fact that
the system will allow the user
to edit the notification
before sending it.
So for example, if I was
responding to my friend
and I clicked I would
love to, I could
continue to edit the response
before sending it and say,
how about I bring my
dog, or something?
Let's look at how you
can make your apps
play nice with this new feature.
I'll show you how you can
enable and disable this feature,
and then I'll show you how you
can generate your own custom
suggestions, and
then I'll show you
how you could
combine your custom
suggestions with
system-generated suggestions.
Let's look at the code.
All right.
The first thing you
want to think about
is to remember that this
applies automatically
to message notifications.
So if your notification
is of type,
CATEGORY_MESSAGE, then
the system automatically
generates suggestions.
You can also make this
happen for other types
of notifications, if you think
this is applicable to them.
The way to turn the
feature on or off
is, if you wanted to
turn on deep links,
the method you're
really looking for
is setAllowSystemGe
neratedContextualActions.
You set it to True
to enable deep links,
and you set it to False
if you don't want this.
By default, the
system turns this on.
Now, for text replies, the
method you're looking for
is setAllowGeneratedReplies.
This was an API that we
introduced in Android P.
You set it to True,
then the system
will automatically generate
text replies for your app.
And you set it to
False, it won't do that.
And then, for Tap to Edit,
the method you're looking for
is setEditChoicesBeforeSending.
You want to set this to Auto.
When you do this, your app will
behave like every other app
on the device.
However, if you really want
to give the user a chance
to edit the response
before they send it,
then you want to
set this to, Yes.
If you want a one-click
action, then you
want to set this to, No.
Next slide.
Cool.
So as I said, you could
generate your own custom replies
and pop them into notifications.
The way the system
really does this is it
runs the content
of the notification
through machine learning models.
So you could train
your own models.
But if you need help to do
this, you could use ML Kit.
ML Kit now features this
new API, called Smart Reply.
What you do is you take the
text of your conversation,
you pass it to Smart
Reply to suggest,
and then it will
return a response
to your callback
with the suggestions.
You can then take
those suggestions
and set them on
your notifications
remote input by calling
setChoices on it.
Whenever you set your own
custom suggestions, what happens
is the system will not generate
suggestions for you anymore.
The reason we do this is so
that the system-generated
suggestions don't conflict
with your custom ones.
But if you really want to
combine these suggestions,
you could do this.
And the trick to doing
this is to understand
how the system really
generates the suggestions.
System uses a system service
called a TextClassifier.
TextClassifier now features
this method, called
suggestConversationActions.
And what you do is you take the
content of the notification,
and you pass it
through this API.
The API then returns
the suggestions for you.
This suggestion includes text
suggestions and deep links
into apps.
I already showed you how
you could set text replies
to your notifications.
But if you wanted to do it for
actions, here's how to do it.
You take the icon, the
title, and the intent
from the action that was
returned by the TextClassifier,
and you use that to build
your own notification.
You also want to
call setContextual,
and you set that to True.
This will enable the system
to render your deep links
the same way the system renders
this in notification actions.
And that's really the
summary of all the things
that you really
need to know about
to get your app to play
nice with this new feature
that we have in
Android Q. Next up
is Mady to talk about Bubbles.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MADY MELLOR Hey, everyone.
So Bubbles is our new
notification-based multitasking
feature in Android.
But before I talk
about Bubbles, I
want to talk a little bit
about System Alert Window.
So System Alert Window has
existed in Android for a while.
And lots of apps have done
really cool things with it,
even though that wasn't really
the intention of this API
to begin with.
Also, unfortunately, apps have
done some less cool things.
So it's a bit of a
security problem.
And it was never meant to be a
heavily used user-facing API,
so it also has performance
implications for the system.
And Android as a
whole is taking steps
to limit apps' abilities
to use this API.
So OK, this is where
Bubbles comes in.
Bubbles is going to be offered
as a platform alternative
to System Alert Window.
So similar to how PIP handles
a lot of the media viewing
use cases, Bubbles is here to
handle the more interactive use
cases.
In Q, Bubbles will be
a developer preview.
You can find it in
developer options,
and you can start
playing with the API
and getting your
apps built with it.
So try Bubbles,
give us feedback,
and it will become the preferred
path over System Alert Window.
In the beta builds, you'll see
it turned on automatically,
but it will be moving
to developer options.
OK.
So the anatomy of a bubble--
you have a collapsed state
and an expanded state.
The collapsed state
has the ability
to post an update out of it.
It's represented as a shape
with a little fly-out.
And then expanded state
shows activity content.
This supports multiple bubbles.
If you've got more, they
would show up in a little row.
OK.
How do you build a bubble?
If you've ever sent an Android
notification, or if you've ever
built an activity, you
can build a Bubble.
It's very straightforward.
First, you're
configuring an activity
to display in a
Bubble, then you're
building a bubble
metadata object,
attaching that to
a notification,
and sending the notification.
So let's look at some code.
Here, we have our
activity definition
in the Android manifest.
There are three things
you need to have
set on your activity
for it to bubble.
It needs to be
embeddable, it needs
to be document
launch mode always,
and it needs to be re-sizable.
If your activity fails
any of these checks,
your notification won't bubble.
It'll just show as a
normal notification.
To construct bubble
metadata, this
is a new API on notifications.
You get the pending intent
for that bubble activity,
and then--
this is very basic.
All you need is an
icon and an intent.
The API has a couple
of other flags
that you can look at in the
developer documentation.
But at minimum, you need
the icon and the activity.
Then you attach this metadata
object to your notification.
So you build a notification
as you normally would,
and then you just do that
one call, set BubbleMetadata,
on it, and then use
Notification Manager to send
the notification.
Now, I might have mentioned that
not everything gets to bubble.
So bubbles are meant for
highly interactive use cases.
They can be convenient,
but they might be annoying
if the user doesn't
find them handy.
They show up on screen.
They take up screen real estate.
They want your attention.
So right now, we're focusing
on messaging, calling,
and user-initiated use cases.
If your notification doesn't
fulfill these requirements,
it won't display as a bubble.
It'll just show as a
normal notification would.
So the nitty-gritty of this.
If you are messaging, you'll
want to use MessageStyle,
and you'll want to have an
inline reply action attached
to the notification.
If you're a phone call, you'll
want to be CATEGORY_CALL.
You'll want to have a person
and foreground service.
And then the user
initiated use case,
we're kind of covering when
your app is in the foreground.
So when your app is
in front of the user,
you can send any kind of
notification as a bubble,
and that'll appear.
Once the app goes out
of the foreground,
that bubble will
remain on screen,
and you can continue
to send updates to it.
OK.
So just to confirm, did that
thing I sent, did it bubble?
You can query
Notification Manager.
Whenever something
is bubbled or when
it's an active
notification, it will appear
in getActiveNotifications.
Then you just can
check the flags of it.
This code gives a little
bit of a sense of it.
Find the notification that
was supposed to bubble,
check if the flag for
FLAG_BUBBLE is enabled,
then you'll know.
OK.
So that's all we've got.
Thank you, for coming
to listen about sharing
improvements, notification
improvements, and bubbles,
and multitasking.
We'll be heading over
to the Android Sandbox,
if you've got questions for us.
So please come find us.
And thanks for listening today.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]